So somebody was saying to me
of something very interesting
about difference in corruption in Nigeria
and corruption in China
and corruption in,
uh, the Gulf.
So it said in the Gulf
you have to hire a prince
and it's a standard 1% commission.
In China, when you're getting a contract,
you pay 10% commission.
But it doesn't affect
your likelihood of getting the contract
because the Chinese officials
are really held to account for deliveries.
So they choose the best contract
they think is gonna deliver on time and on budget
and then take the 10% commission.
I know that Zhang Ping
having had his big crackdown. Corruption.
I don't know where I saw this.
The average weight and the waist size
of Chinese civil servants
has diminished since this anti corruption.
Since the anti corruption drive.
Because they're not as fat as they used to be.